[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen my
name is David Thoreau and I'm the
president of the independent Institute
we're especially delighted to welcome
you to this evening our special program
is entitled the meaning and reality of
individual sovereignty with a renowned
scholar and best-selling author Jordan V
Peterson for those of you who may be new
to the independent Institute you'll find
information on us in the printed program
that hopefully you received the
independent Institute is a nonprofit
nonpartisan public policy research
organization that sponsors in-depth
studies of major social and economic
issues the purpose is to bowl the
advance peaceful prosperous and free
societies grounded in a commitment to
human dignity in the process we seek
robust
dialogue of key issues and we stand
against efforts to shut down their free
exchange of ideas the results of our
work are publishes books and form the
basis for numerous conference and media
programs
neither seeking or accepting government
funding we hope that you will join our
lighthouse society within just a couple
years Jordan Peterson has taken the
world by storm
indeed has become a profound and
powerful phenomenon in the midst of the
cultural confusion of our age a
courageous articulate and sparkling
champion of free speech individual
liberty personal responsibility free
markets civic virtue the rule of law and
the judeo-christian values that underpin
Western civilization but er Peterson has
burst onto the public scene with his
incisive critiques of political
correctness identity politics moral
relativism post-modernism and
collectivism and statism on the left and
right here's just a sampling of the many
memorable quotes by him quote don't
compare yourself with other people
compare yourself with who you were
yesterday unquote or free speech is not
just another value is the foundation of
Western civilization
don't lie about anything ever
lying leads to hell we have to
rediscover the eternal values that and
then live them out no one gets away with
anything ever so take responsibility for
your own life now what is remarkable is
that such common sense and enduring
wisdom has been so sadly lacking in the
public square but what is also so
astounding and encouraging is the
enormous interest dr. Peterson is
generating globally in restoring first
principles all through the number 1
international bestseller 12 rules for
life an antidote to chaos Jordan
Peterson is professor of psychology at
the University of Toronto he is also
author of the book maps of meaning the
architecture of belief plus over 100
scientific papers and he has almost 2
million subscribers to his YouTube
channel his work explores the modern
world by combining the hard-won truths
of ancient tradition with the stunning
revelations of cutting-edge science now
you can read further details about his
background on the program that hopefully
you got but I will just add one
additional note he's a native of North
Western Canada
2016 he was inducted as an honorary
member of the quacky to tell tribe in
the Pacific Northwest and given the name
al esta la gee meaning great seeker
please join me in welcoming Jordan B
Peterson
[Applause]
well thank you all for coming it's good
to see you here the meaning and reality
of individual sovereignty that's a
fundamental question as far as I'm
concerned because it's by no means
self-evident why the idea of individual
sovereignty should be granted the
primacy of place that it has been
granted or you could say it another way
the reasons that that proposition have
been deemed self-evident are not obvious
so when I was just backstage I was
looking at the Declaration of
Independence which I do quite regularly
make sure that I've got that especially
the introductory statements formulated
properly and the introductory statements
I won't quote them precisely but they
lay out a series of propositions and the
first is that we hold these truths to be
self-evident and that people are endowed
by their creator with certain
inalienable rights that they're equal
and that government is to govern bike by
the consent of individuals and those are
axiomatic statements right there are
this sort of statements that you build a
system from you have to accept the
statements first before you can build
the system and it's analogous in some
sense to Euclidean geometry right
there's a set of axioms and you accept
them and then you can build a system but
you have to accept the axioms but you
don't have to accept the axioms that's
the thing and one of the things that's
very much worth understanding is that
the current culture war that were
embroiled in
which really has been going on for in
some ways for thousands of years but in
other ways for more specifically
political ways I suppose since the rise
of Marxism about a hundred and fifty
years ago it depends on how you analyze
it whether you think about it is
political or psychological because as a
psychological phenomena it's much older
the the proposition that those truths
that are laid out in the Declaration of
Independence are self-evident is no
longer accepted by a large number of
people let's say in the intellectual
academy and I would say that's
particularly true of the post modernists
it's also true of the Marxists and the
post modernists and the Marxists have
United in a very strange manner because
their philosophies are not really
commensurate with one another the post
modernists profess skepticism about
meta-narratives large-scale stories that
perhaps might might serve as a uniting
structures for people's own cognitive
contents but also that unites groups of
people across large swaths of territory
they profess skepticism about the
validity of those narratives and yet
well the problem with that is it leaves
you nowhere because if you don't have a
uniting narrative a uniting story of
uniting any ethos you don't have an
explanation for your existence in the
world and you don't have a direction and
that's not helpful because you can't
live without an explanation for your
existence in the world and a direction
or if you do live under those conditions
you're bound to be miserable and the
reason you're bound to be miserable is
because and I would say that this is
technically true that almost all the
positive emotion that you're going to
experience in your life is a consequence
of pursuing valuable goals it's not a
consequence of attaining
it's a consequence of positing them
aiming at them and then observing
yourself moving towards them and that
the sense that accompanies that and we
know the neurobiology of this sense
actually quite well the sense of that is
one of forward movement and engagement
and meaning and accomplishment it's
something like that
hope that's another way of thinking
about it and it's the antidote in some
sense to the flip side of life which is
the fact that it's nasty brutish and
short as Thomas Hobbes put it and that's
inalienable as well there's no escape
from the limitations and suffering of
life and so in order for that not to
become overwhelming and then that can
easily become overwhelming and often
does in people's lives
then you need a countervailing set of
propositions that you can act out and
embody to endow that limitation with
worth and that's a not a trivial problem
I was just debating not really
slava Dziedzic about a week ago and two
weeks ago maybe and I was debating him
because he had been advertised to me and
many others as sort of the world's
foremost Marxist scholar and it turned
out that he really was not much of a
Marxist at all and so I ended up
criticizing the communist manifesto
which deserves criticism and and then I
expected him to defend it but he didn't
and so that was sort of interesting but
non blessing um but he said something
very interesting during that debate and
it came all of a sudden it came out of
the blue you know and I think it was the
most striking part of the entire
and this is just a strange segue but I'm
trying I want to I need to discuss this
because it struck me so hard because I
think it's such an important point I'd
never thought about it before so he told
me something I'd never thought about
before at all he was talking about the
Christian passion and he said that his
sense was that the most important part
of it was the scene let's say where
Christ is crucified and cries out to God
that he's been Forsaken and he said look
you think gotta think about what that
means I'm paraphrasing him he said that
the suffering that characterizes
individual human life is so intense that
even if God Himself
Dane's to undergo it it will test his
faith to the point where he will not
believe in his own existence that's
really something and I thought wow
that's such a brilliant that's such a
brilliant observation is that because
it's definitely the case you know if you
if you if you interact with people in
any manner that's the least bit below
the surface you find out that most
people are carrying a relatively heavy
existential burden of one form or
another you know I mean most people many
people have a physical illness that
they're dealing with or a mental illness
that they're dealing with and if you're
in a fortunate position where you're not
dealing with either of those you
probably have a family member that does
and if you don't have either of those
you will that's for sure and and you
know that's just one of many terrible
catastrophes that are certain to visit
you and that terrible catastrophe is a
challenge to us in many ways it's a
challenge to us because it forces us to
look deeply for a countervailing meaning
that can make sense out of that and then
maybe more than makes sense out of it
and and so I've been curious about
whether or not that countervailing
meaning exists you know the post
modernists the first thing about them
especially the identity politics types I
never know really
what to call this group of people
because if I call them postmodern
neo-marxists then I'm accused of being
all right conspiracy theorists and if if
I if I call them collectivists well
that's accurate in some sense but not
not precisely and I could call them
identity politics players and that
happens on the right and the left but
that's the basic rubric I would say that
uniting idea is that the individual is a
fiction in some sense and the right
level of analysis for society and the
political scene and and the economic
scene is the group right is who you are
as an individual is well first of all
perhaps that's just in losery category
altogether but who you are is going to
be defined essentially in terms of your
group identity your gender your sex
that's already 70 different things your
your that'd be funny if it wasn't true
your your maybe your socioeconomic
status your class that was the original
Marxist
definition of identity right because
Marx believed that history was a war
between two classes and that your
fundamental being was established by
your class identity or it's your
ethnicity or your race those are two
other fundamental group identities or
it's some combination of them all which
is intersectionality which is something
that sort of devours itself and I've
done a little bit of mathematics it's
like if you could imagine that you
belong to ten groups you know ten
canonical groups there's probably like
one of you and so if you get
intersectional enough one of the things
that happens is that you break the
group's all the way down to the level of
the individual if you're gonna take
someone's group centered peculiarities
entirely into account you end up with
ends of one and I actually think that
that's what the West figured out
thousands of
years ago was that if you were gonna
take everyone's uniqueness into account
in the way the intersection lists appear
to want to do with the plethora of group
identities that you end up at the
individual and so but it but there's no
requirement for coherency on the part of
the postmodernists and in fact they
believe that coherency is actually I
would say something akin to a conspiracy
theory that's part I'm dead serious I'm
absolutely dead serious about this it's
a it's a conspiracy theory on the part
of the modernists who invented or
elaborated the oppressive patriarchy
that we all exist under which is
something akin I suppose to
Marx's proletariat versus Barozzi it's
some mishmash of idiocy like that and
but you know I mean it's there's a
question there that that's worth
answering it's like well why do we
believe in the individual you know the
founders of the people who wrote the
Declaration of Independence know it's
like they justified it right they said
we hold these truths as self-evident
like that's not an argument that's just
a statement it's like and it starts a
statement like a game in some sense it's
like well let's assume these things are
true and move on from there and see what
happens now they had their reasons you
know like from a Canadian perspective
the people who the America you Americans
who ran a revolution against England
you're just Englishmen that we're after
their own rights and and I've been
denied by by by your colonial status but
the American system is deeply embedded
in the English common law system and
it's deeply embedded in well whatever
gave rise to the English common law
system and certainly part of that is the
judeo-christian tradition I don't I
don't think any of that's particularly
debatable and and so I've been very
interested in what makes these problems
self-evident to look to see if there's
any truth in the sub structure that
makes for the self evidence and so I'm
gonna lay out some propositions for you
today we'll see how many I can get to as
there's a number of them that are
important I think I'll start first of
all with a little discussion of Genesis
I did a biblical series in 2017 on
Genesis which some of you might be
interested in either watching or
listening to it's actually being very
popular which is very peculiar
I rented a theater of about this size to
give the lectures and it sold out 15
lectures on Genesis and almost all the
people who came were men which is
completely incomprehensible because you
can't get men near a church and you know
and and they were usually men and I
would say between about 28 and 40 25 and
40 something like that
and so it was pretty interesting that
they came and the most popular lecture I
ever gave on YouTube is on the first
sentence of Genesis it's like two and a
half hours on the first sentence of
Genesis you never think anything like
that could possibly be popular but I
want to tell you a little bit about
Genesis because I think it's I think
there are things in it that are well
they're what make the self evidence
self-evident but I also think that
they're also true they're true
metaphorically for sure they're true
psychologically I believe and they might
be true metaphysically but I don't know
because no one knows about that and you
know that's where you're when you're
speaking of ultimate things your
knowledge runs out and so but I'll stick
to the metaphorical and the
psychological that'll do you know so the
way Genesis is structured it's quite
interesting there's three elements that
are discussed as constituting the being
it's not it's not a theory of the
material existence like a scientific
theory
it's not that it's a theory of being so
it it's and that's a hard thing to
understand in itself you could think
about it as a theory of the structure of
experience that's another way of
thinking about it you know you have
experience of the world and you have
your emotions and your motivations and
you have your aims and your stories and
your thoughts your there's a
characteristic human mode of existence
that's conscious we're aware that things
exist and we we live within that
structure and as far as I can tell
given that Genesis is certainly not a
scientific account of the structure of
the University it has to be some account
of some other of something else and it's
it's an account of experience itself and
maybe experience itself is the ultimate
reality and it depends to some degree on
how you define ultimate it depends also
on how you define reality but you can
play that game you can say well let's
assume that it's just that your
experience is reality it's certainly
reality as far as you're concerned I
mean especially and I would say one of
the things about that that make that
self-evident is pain like there's
there's nothing like pain to convince
you that your experience is real I don't
know anyone who isn't convinced that
their experience is real by pain and the
only people I know that might be
unconvinced just haven't had enough pain
because if they did they'd be convinced
there's no arguing it away in Genesis
there's God and it's God the Father
which applies something like a structure
you know like like a patriarchal
structure that that might be one way of
thinking about like a hierarchical
structure it's not surprising because
God would be at the pinnacle of the
hierarchy and there's the logos which is
the word that God uses to create order
out of chaos and so there's God and
there's the logos that's the Word of God
and then there's the chaos and the chaos
is Tohu bohu or tail those are the
original words and they're Dera there
from older words from Sumeria from word
Tiamat and timeout or Tiamat was a
Sumerian goddess a dragon like a
subterranean
no no Fillion monster who lived in the
salt water or who was the salt water
it's not exactly clear and she was taken
apart by the Sumerian creator god Marduk
who was a hero type like Bo wolf or like
Bilbo in in in in The Hobbit its Bilbo
in The Hobbit isn't or is Frodo
doesn't matter it's one of those little
hobbits anyways and he he confronts time
at who has decided in the justify of
bull fit of anger in some sense I'll
tell you the whole story
Tiamat there's two gods Tiamat and AB su
Tiamat is the goddess of the salt water
and absolu is the goddess of the fresh
water and as far as the Sumerians were
concerned there was the land and
underneath the land there was fresh
water and under lease the fresh water
there was salt water and the world was a
dome on top of that and that was the
same conceptual world that the people
who wrote Genesis lived in and it's it's
kind of how the world looks if you go
outside in the field looks like there's
a dome there's some ground if you dig
down you hit salt water or fresh water
and then you know surrounding that
there's salt water and so that's the
world and they thought of the salt water
in the fresh water as God and Goddess
salt water being the goddess fresh water
being the God and then it was the union
of absolute time at that produced the
first generation of children gods and
they were active sort of proto-human
creatures greater than human but
human-like and they made an awful lot of
racket and they were very careless and
they killed apps ooh and then they tried
to make their abode on his corpse that's
a very smart idea AB Suze you could
think about him
the representation of the patriarchy you
know society itself and the idea that
the Mesopotamians came up with in this
mystical dramatic way was that were
careless we tend to kill our society and
we try to live on its corpse and that's
exactly right and it's always been right
and that's then that that stories
thousands of years old and it was a
foundation story for a very
sophisticated civilization and it still
affects the stories that we live by
today and it's a brilliant idea because
of course you were handed your society
and you know you may be doing everything
you can to derive as much benefit as you
possibly can from it without
contributing it to it in the least and
so it's it's something dead in that it's
the past and it's something that you can
you can mmm what would you say it's not
manipulate precisely you can exploit
that's your privilege how to exploit or
exploitation anyways they kill apps ooh
stupidly and that makes timeout very mad
and so she comes back and says well I'm
just wipe you all out it's like the
flood it's it's the same kind of story
as knowing the flood which is also a
very common kind of story and this new
God comes up his name is Marduk and he
has eyes all the way around his head and
he speaks magic words both of which are
very important features because the fact
that he has eyes all the way around his
head means he pays attention and the the
fact that he speaks magic words means
that he's a master of communication and
he goes out to fight time out and he
successfully cuts her into pieces and he
makes the world and so she's the goddess
of chaos and destruction the goddess of
nature and the idea is that that entity
that confronts the chaotic unknown cuts
it into pieces and makes the habitable
world which is exactly right it's
exactly right it's exactly what you do
and then that's what I want to get out
if I can get to it
it's hard it's a hard story to tell
anyways that story is at the bottom of
the story of Genesis and so God
confronts the Tohu verbo who or the tale
with logos and logos gets elaborated
over the course of centuries into a very
complex idea first of all logos is or
turns into Christ which is very strange
thing so there's the Christ in
Christianity who's there at the
beginning of time and then is incarnated
in history and is there at the end of
time it's a very strange notion so
something that's eternal and is always
there but also in car incarnated in a
specific time and at a specific
arbitrary place right so it's this
principle that is also so it's Universal
and eternal and also local both at the
same time very very important idea and
very much relevant to what a human being
is like as far as I'm concerned and God
uses the logos the word and he interacts
with the Tohu vibhut who the chaos and
eden generates order and that's what
happens in Genesis and he generates
order over a number of days using the
logos and every time he generates a new
form of order so each day he says and it
was good and so that's interesting hey
because first of all it's not obvious
that it's good that goes back to the
comment that Slava jejak made it's like
here we are in this being that's being
being constructed in this reality and
it's very it's very difficult reality
human beings are very for us
our lives are bounded limited we're
mortal we suffer and if we suffer enough
injustice or justice even sometimes if
we suffer enough it's very easy for us
to turn against being and to curse it
and it's not surprising and this is why
she Jack's words hit me so so hard
because when he said that that suffering
had become so intense that even God
himself would have doubts about
the benevolence of himself in some sense
that's what that moment means on the
cross it's like well what in the world
would you expect from mere human beings
and so but there's this insistence in
Genesis that things that are created as
a consequence of the logos are good so
first that they're created by the logos
and second that they're good and so
that's a very interesting set of
propositions so the logos tis true is
something like truthful speech and so
this is partly what makes me a free
speech advocate because I don't think
that you can get to truthful speech
without like speeches and speeches
dialogical what you don't know much and
you don't know much and neither do you
like we're full of biases and we and and
blind spots and even when you're trying
to formulate your thoughts clearly
you're not that good at it especially if
you're thinking about something complex
and chaotic and unknown and you're gonna
have to stumble around madly and make
all sorts of mistakes to make any
progress at all and with any luck you
know you'll be able to talk to other
people and they'll be just as clueless
about it as you but out of that
dialogical process if you're actually
trying to communicate something
approximating the truth will emerge and
hopefully the truth will set us free as
its supposed to and put us on the proper
path you see the thing about the
collectivist types at the universities
you know they're they're very interested
in shutting down free speech but you
have to understand that it's not because
they oppose the views of the people that
they're trying to shut down it is that
but because they don't believe that
there's such a thing as free speech
because they don't believe that there's
such a thing as individuals they believe
that you're just the avatar of your
group and that whatever your opinions
are are conditioned socially constructed
and the reason they're socially
constructed is because you're born in a
certain hierarchy of identity and that
hierarchy of identity has conditioned
every single thing you say so you might
think that you're expressing your
opinion but if you're a postmodernist
you don't have an opinion because there
isn't a you
you're just the mouthpiece of your
privilege for your lack of privilege and
so the debate on campuses isn't about
who should speak and who shouldn't speak
although it does degenerate into that
the debate is way more fundamental than
that and it is well whether there is
anyone who has anything to say because
the battleground for the post modernists
is nothing but identity groups at war
with one another for dominance and
that's it and so this war is way deeper
than you think it's not who should speak
it's whether there is such a thing as
free speech all right so back to human
beings I might manage this so it's an
amazing idea first of all that it's this
capacity for cumulative for speech and
and for attention because I think the
logos is a combination of that like
Marduk you know Marduk has all his eyes
and he's able to speak magic words and
so and he's one source of the idea for
what the logo says another source is
there's an Egyptian source it's often
identified with Christ as a god named
Horus and you all know about Horus
because you all know about the Egyptian
I you've all seen the famous Egyptian I
and Horus is the god of attention and
he's often identified with a falcon and
our bird of prey and that's because the
only creatures that can see better than
human beings are birds of prey
so Eagles for example Bald Eagles they
have an eye the same size as ours and
they have two central you know use your
central vision to look at things because
you know if you look right at someone
you notice you can see them but you
can't really see the people off to the
side they start to fade out you have a
foe via in the middle of your eye which
is very very high resolution but Eagles
have two of those and so they can see
better than us eagle can see a dime from
the top of the Empire State Building
although why an eagle would be
interested in that isn't obvious
but that's the acuity of their vision
anyways the Egyptians one of the
Egyptians gods that was identified with
the Pharaoh and therefore was
sovereignty was Horus and it was Horus
as I in particular his eye his capacity
to pay attention that made him part of
what constituted sovereignty so there's
this idea that complicated idea that you
have to pull out of multiple sources
that the capacity to pay attention and
the capacity to speak truthfully takes
chaos and transforms it into order into
into cosmos and that that order is good
and so that so that's the second part of
the the proposition it's a very
interesting it's a daring proposition
the first proposition is something like
consciousness communicative
consciousness interacts with the
underlying chaotic structure of reality
and brings existence into being now we
don't really know if that's true there
are physicists who suspect that it's
true we know that who suspect that
without consciousness whatever
consciousness is there'd be nothing but
something like a vague potential that it
requires consciousness to bring
structured that potential to make
existence exist and people argue about
that no one's exactly sure what it means
but but there are physicists who believe
that very strongly and well and it's
definitely an open question for example
the an open question of what it is that
could exist if there was nothing
conscious of its existence now I don't
know existence seems to be one of those
things that requires consciousness to be
it's like no consciousness well what is
there well it's not even it's not
possible answer there's no duration
there's no size there's no quality
there's there's there's nothing and it's
a mystery it's I'm not saying it's a
mystery we
understand but implicit in the idea of
existence consciousness seems to be
implicit in the idea of existence and it
does seem that we're conscious and so
consciousness interacts with chaos to
produce order and if it's truthful and
attentive consciousness then the order
it produces from chaos is good that's
the next proposition and that's a daring
proposition it's an ethical proposition
so the first proposition in Genesis is
like an ontological or epistemological
proposition it's sort of about the
nature of reality but the second is an
ethical proposition and it's a really
interesting one and I think this is this
is I don't know if there's a more
interesting question that you can ask
yourself it's like because the
proposition is that what you bring into
the world when you interact with chaos
what is brought into the world in the
interaction with chaos as a consequence
of truth if that's what's embodied in
the logos is by definition good and so
one of the things I've been suggesting
to my audiences it's one of the rules in
my book is that you should tell the
truth or at least you shouldn't lie it's
like you can't tell the truth because
what the hell do you know but but you
cannot lie you know like each of us
knows when we're about to utter
something that isn't true
now sometimes maybe you're confused
about it because you're ignorant and
you're biased and and so you say
something and it might be true it might
not be but you know it clear about it
but sometimes it's pretty damn clear
that you say something or you do
something that you know perfectly well
not to be true and you do it anyways and
the proposition that Genesis puts
forward is if you act in truth then the
order you produce is good regardless of
how it appears
it's an axiomatic statement of ethical
it's an axiomatic ethical proposition
that you're that the job of whatever
extracts order from chaos
is properly done if it's done in truth
and that's that's worth thinking about
because it might be true and then the
question is like well do you believe
it's true that's a good question
it's not a religious question even it's
a practical question as far as I'm
concerned and my sense is that people
just believe that this is true deeply
and the way you can tell that is not by
what they say but by what they do and so
for example one of the things that you
might observe is that you know if you
love someone your children let's say you
don't tell them that's the best way to
get through the world is to lie about
everything all the time you don't sit
down you don't sit them down and say
look this is a corrupt Enterprise and
all together and you can't trust anyone
because they're always lying about
everything and your job is to become the
best liar you possibly can become
because that's the way to get to where
you need to get to and to set the world
straight no one ever does that and so if
they don't do that which would be belief
in the lie then they must assume
something that's approximately opposite
and I would say that most people are not
pleased when they catch their children
in a lie and so then you have to ask
well why is that it has to be because
people believe that the truth is the
proper way to proceed and what isn't
obvious why they believe that but it's
obvious that they act as if they do
believe that and then I would also say
well there's more to it than that
because we know for example that
societies that have a high level of
trust and there aren't that many of
those in the world they happen to almost
all be Western societies where there's a
high level of trust there's a high level
of economic development they're
unbelievably highly associated and I've
never been able to figure out how
countries ever became not
corrupt like it just seems completely
impossible to me for countries that were
corrupt once to ever become not corrupt
I don't understand how that happens at
all but there's a handful of countries
in the world that are fundamentally not
corrupt where your default print
proposition presupposition when you deal
with a stranger let's say in a financial
transaction is that you don't have to be
on guard like you're investigating a pit
of vipers because the person is likely
to act out what they say they'll do and
it it reduces the transaction the
unnecessary transaction costs to about
zero right because I can take you at
your word we don't know each other I can
take you at your word a good example
that is eBay
you know because eBay was stranger
transactions and people were concerned
it would degenerate into an unplayable
game and turned out that the default
trade on eBay was like if you have 98%
seller rating on eBay you're actually a
crook you know you need you need
ninety-nine percent or above it's so
high it's unbelievable
so so we do we do know that trust is
necessary we do assume that people
shouldn't lie we are upset if our
children don't tell the truth we feel
that that's a moral failing but we're
not very courageous because we won't
live the full we won't live out the full
implications of that so the third part
of Genesis that I'd like to concentrate
on very briefly is the part that makes
the Declaration of Independence
self-evident and that is that man and
woman alike are made in the image of God
and that's a very mysterious statement
because well first of all it seems on
the face of it absurd partly because it
turns God into something approximating a
person because there's an equation there
and that it's not obvious what that
might mean it's also not clear what
being made in the image of God would
mean given that by that point in the
book you don't know much about God
except that you do know the
he uses logos to extract order out of
chaos that's about all you know and that
that's good and so the proposition there
as far as I'm concerned is that that's
what human beings do that's what we do
and and that this is way more important
than people think that we are
co-creators of reality now you think
well do you believe that well let's
let's let's think about that for a
minute or two it's like you know the
standard scientists they tend to think
of human beings as materialist and
deterministic I don't think that works
very well for consciousness I don't
think there's any evidence that it works
as an explanation for consciousness at
all and I think so I think consciousness
is self-evident I mean we certainly act
as if it's self-evident you act like
you're conscious you act like all the
people around you are conscious they're
not happy if you don't act like they're
conscious that's for sure you're not
going to get along with yourself or your
family members or society at large if
you don't treat people like they're
conscious you're also not going to get
along with any of them unless you treat
them like they are active agents that
have some role in determining their own
destiny right I mean God you see that in
two-year-olds you know when they're
already pushing for autonomy and so we
make these assumptions that while we
have this capacity for autonomous choice
and I'm gonna split an argument into two
parts here the first thing is I don't
think that we can be deterministic
because it looks like neurobiologically
that if you want to run
deterministically like on habit which
would be what deterministically would be
you have to practice and practice and
practice and practice and practice and
build all the machinery that allows you
to act deterministically and then
there'll be a stimulus and the whole
deterministic process will lay itself
out but that doesn't happen unless
you've built the machinery so like if
you're a tennis pro you know you're
acting deterministically all the time
because you don't have enough time to
consciously decide what you're going to
do when a ball is come
you so fast you can't actually see it
properly it's all reflux but it's really
complicated chains of reflexes and you
spent like ten thousand dollars building
them and so fine and when you're driving
your car you're walking you're doing
these things that you've practiced so
well well your deterministic but when
you can counter the chaos of the day
that's a whole different story
and so what consciousness seems to do
actually is to act when deterministic
processes aren't at hand so and so what
we could walk through that we say look
look here - here here's one way of
thinking about yourself you're you're a
clock and you're wound up and you wind
down mechanistically but the clock
mechanism has to be there for you to
wind down mechanistically and unless
you've practiced something a long time
it's not there so I don't see how
determined ISM can account for that so
here's an alternative and you can tell
me if this is in keeping with your
experience so you wake up in the morning
your consciousness re-emerges from the
darkness in which it's been embedded
like the Sun coming up just why
consciousness has always been associated
with the Sun or we're daytime creatures
and we and we're creatures of vision and
so we identify consciousness within with
the light with illumination with
enlightenment you wake up in the morning
and what do you have in front of you
well it depends whether you're excited
or worried but it doesn't it doesn't
really matter because it's the same
thing what you have in front of you this
is as far as I can tell is that you have
a field of possibility you have a field
of potential you might wake up and worry
you think well I have to do this or you
know this series of negative
consequences might emerge and I have
these obligations that need to be taken
care of for the same reason duties you
know tax bills that have to be open
before they turn into some sort of
terrible monster or work work
requirements that need to be done for
the same reason to keep to keep chaos at
bay and that will run through your mind
and if it's overwhelming if there's too
much chaos in your life you might wake
up in the middle of the night and have
all that running through your head you
have all these this potent
so of what could be manifesting itself
in front of you and then that's that
that can be very stressful it can also
be very exciting right because the
flipside of that obligation is
opportunity and so you see in front of
you this field of potential that's
opportunity but what what what you see
as far as I can tell with your
consciousness is the potential that
could be right you see a sequence of
worlds that you have some causal ability
to bring into being and and you act like
that you think well I have to do this
because then this will happen or if I
don't do this then this will happen and
hopefully if you're not too skewed most
of the decisions you make are positive
ones because you want to take the
potential that's in front of you the
chaos and you want to turn it into a
reality that's good and most of the time
you're going to assume although you may
be tempted not to from time to time that
the best way to do that is to confront
that potential forthrightly and to deal
with it in a positive and truthful
manner and that the hopeful consequence
of that will be that well even if you
don't produce something good it will be
less hellish than it might have been
right but maybe you'll maybe you'll get
lucky because you're focused and you're
doing your best and you're confronting
what's there as potential and you turn
it into something good and then you can
live with yourself properly and you
don't wake up in the middle of the night
and bemoan your lost opportunities and
your lost possibilities and so I think
that what we are as individuals are
spirits that confront the potential of
reality and transform it into the
actuality of reality as a consequence of
our ethical decisions that's what it
looks like and I think that that's why
there's an insistence in Genesis that
were made in the image of God because
we're partaking
in the same process continually and you
know you think well do you believe that
well huh let's look at how you act
I mean first thing is you tend to think
you your kids is full of potential and
and you tend to think of the world that
confronts them as full of opportunity I
mean or full of potential for that
matter the whole potential thing is very
strange notion and we don't think about
it much and I think it's mostly because
we're materialistic it's like there's
nothing material about potential it's
not here it's not here now
it's it's out there whatever that means
in the future with no qualities
whatsoever except our apprehension of it
it has no weight it has no mass it has
no has no being whatsoever it's just
what could be but we treat it as it is
if it's more real than anything else
what could be and then if we have
children and they don't live up to their
potential they don't take advantage of
their opportunities then we're angry at
them we say you had this potential that
you could have done something with and
you didn't do it and so that you've
sacrificed your own potential by not
taking advantage of this opportunity and
you've made yourself in the world less
than it could be and you're never happy
about that not when you're dealing with
someone that you love you're always
upset because you see very clearly that
they are not being who they could be and
you and you see very clearly that that's
a downward path and it's definitely not
something that you want for your
children then you think - well what
about how you treat other people use
yourself well conscience is a good
example of that you let an opportunity
go by so you have some potential that
manifests itself in front of you
as a doorway through which you could
pass and maybe you you forego the
opportunity because you're faithless and
unafraid and I mean that happens to
everyone
but it doesn't mean that you're gonna
let yourself off the hook for that you
know if you look at older people and you
ask them what they regret in their lives
it's not the opportunities they took
it's the opportunities they could have
taken and didn't and it's because
I believe that deep in their conscience
part of our structure our deep deep
structure we have an own moral
obligation to take what's offered to us
in its full catastrophe and to make the
best of it and to do that properly with
our ethical choices and that we do not
let ourselves off the hook if we fail at
that and then I don't believe that we
can organize our human relationships
without believing that because if I
believe you have no agency and no
capacity for your own choice and your
own I believe you have no ability to
transform the future into the into the
present into the into the reality of the
present I'm going to be you're going to
react to that like it's demeaning and
patronizing I have to treat you like a
moral agent of worth I have to do that
to me I have to do that to my kids I
have to do that to my friends and if we
don't try to establish a community like
a political community and we don't use
that as an axiom then the political
community is a bloody catastrophe
and so that's part of what makes me
think that this sort of thing is real
it's like well it's real enough so that
it governs your relationship with
yourself whether you want it to or not
it's real enough that it governs your
relationship with your children and
their and the rest of your family it's
real enough that if you don't build your
political system with those self-evident
axioms then you just get a catastrophic
tyranny it's like that's pretty real so
those are the self-evident propositions
and so I've been talking to people and
trying to remind them of this you know
because we're in danger of losing this
and we shouldn't be losing it because
there's something about it that seems to
be correct I think people are afraid of
it and then they should be I mean one of
the statements with regards to my
introduction was that my observation as
a clinician was that no one ever got
away with anything
and I believe that I've seen that
because you'd make a mistake especially
a conscious mistake and you think you've
got away with it
you wait it'll come back years later
something something you bent the fabric
of reality in some manner and in the
short term you got away with it you know
no one noticed but that has consequences
that unfold and sooner or later that
chickens come home to roost and
sometimes it takes years if you're doing
therapy with someone and they've gone
off on a very bad pathway to trace all
the decisions all the way back to that
one decision you made that you knew was
wrong when you made it and you made it
anyways and then you forgot about it
because you don't remember every
decision you make and your life is going
off astray in some terrible manner I've
been suggesting to people and this is
and I'll close with this first of all
you have this moral obligation because
you have this potential in front of you
and the hypothesis is that you should be
approaching that let's say with courage
and truth and transforming it into the
best that you can transform it into
because that's actually the world and
you do that locally you do that to the
limits of your power and sometimes you
don't have much power because you're not
that competent and sometimes you have a
lot of power and you're very competent
but it doesn't matter you have a certain
amount of potential at hand and you can
either transform it into the order
that's good or you can do the opposite
and generate a little bit of hell right
here and now and if enough of us do that
then we get a very large amount of Hell
right here and now and we've seen that
multiple times particularly in the 20th
century with the establishment of great
totalitarian regimes that were based on
nothing but lies that were as close to
hell as anyone could possibly desire
sort of metaphysical reality but it's
worse - it's not only I think that
you're called upon
this is a responsibility you're called
upon to act ethically in the face of
this potential that confronts you so
that what you produce is good but
there's there's there's there's a part
of that that's worse that it's that's
more burdensome than that even if that's
burdensome enough make a mistake bring
something into reality that shouldn't be
there then it's there and then it's
there to plague you and it's there to
plague the people around you and it's
not gonna go away till someone fixes it
so that's a scary thing but the other
thing is is that even if you if you fail
to take the responsibility that's laden
upon you to use truth to structure
possibility properly then you leave a
hole in the structure of being that you
could have filled with something good
and it doesn't just stay there as a
whole it's that you invite something
that's terrible in to take its place and
that's what happens when people become
bitter and resentful and cynical because
they've been hurt in their lives and
they start to use deception and they
start to deviate from the desire to
confront the potential that surrounds
them properly and to make things better
they they look for revenge they look to
hurt they they develop malevolent
motives and then not only are you not
bringing into the world what could be
good and sustaining but you're inviting
into the world what can definitely be
hellish is the only greater to properly
conceptualize it and so I think that
there isn't anything more meaningful or
real than the idea of individual
sovereignty and that it's mostly
predicated on not on rights but on
responsibility which is where our
cultural conversation has gone wrong
because we've been talking about rights
forever it's like you have a
responsibility
you're you're given a modicum of
possibility to play with in your life to
do something with to build something
with and what you build is dependent on
your ethical choices and it's the sum
total of those ethical choices that
create the world and then I'll close
with this
we actually believe this politically
because our Western systems which are
quite functional are also predicated on
the idea that you're sovereign well what
does that mean what means the government
has to respect your rights but like I
said we've talked too much about rights
there's more to it than that
the proposition is that the state is
blind and old and decayed and dead and
that requires the vision and the truth
of the living in order to keep it on
track and so what you do to keep it on
track is you consult the living each one
of us as sovereign individuals and the
reason you do that is because of the
proposition that you could actually do
that you could open your eyes you could
see what was in front of you you could
speak the truth and you could keep the
ship of state properly afloat and
oriented in the correct direction and
our entire society is predicated on that
idea as well and so that's the
responsibility right and it's it's a
burdensome and terrible responsibility
but I also think given the fundamental
catastrophe of life and the fact that
you have to deal with that without
becoming embittered that you need a
weight and a load of responsibility
that's of sufficient magnitude and worth
so that it balances the fragility that
characterizes you you could make things
better
you could reduce suffering in the world
you could act in a meaningful and
truthful way and there would be nothing
in that but good if it was good that you
wanted
and that's all at the bottom of what
constitutes the self evidence of our
equality before God our inalienable
rights and the requirement for the
consent of the governed thank you
Thank You dr. Peterson we would now like
to engage in conversation with dr.
Peterson drawing on questions we've
received from many of you and joining
with us now are two of my colleagues at
the independent Institute the first is
Mary Thoreau is senior vice president
and Graham Walker who was executive
director Mary received a degree in
economics from Stanford University as
she's been chairman of Garvey
international co-founder president and
CEO of San Francisco grocery Express and
member the National Board of the
Salvation Army as well as chairman of
the Salvation Army here in San Francisco
and in the East Bay Graham received his
PhD in public law and government from
the university of notre dom he's been a
professor at Catholic University of
America and the University of
Pennsylvania as well as the scholar in
the social science at the Institute for
Advanced Study in Princeton Mary do you
want to begin thank you thank you that
was just terrific we really appreciate
your being here and you gave us a lot to
talk about I've heard you say that we
humans are more sensitive to negative
emotion than too positive and in fact
that we're tilted to negative emotion in
terms of its potency but the enormous
popularity of your message where you
cast a vision that we can overcome
problems and we can achieve lives of
meaning and love and resiliency shows
the tremendous hunger that exists for
that positive alternative in the realm
in which independent operates
politicians Tipler typically do employ a
threat based narrative so the world's
going to end in ten years unless you
give us control of the economy with a
green new dough right
in which case it will certainly end in
ten years absolutely
so as with your messaging independent
cast the possibilities based vision we
produce publications and commentary and
other things that it's positive
solutions-oriented has an opportunity
based narrative emphasizing how human
ingenuity operating within a virtuous
framework of the free market can
overcome virtually every challenge
including improving lives and providing
solutions to problems that governments
can't or actually make worse so my
question is given your observation
regarding the outside appeal of the
negative how would you advise us and
indeed anybody in the audience who wants
to counter that negative that threat
based narrative and advance the
opportunity human valuing narrative well
that's a great question I mean there's
an old old idea that you have to rescue
your dead father from an abyss and that
sort of associated in some sense with
the Nietzschean idea of the death of God
and when every generation goes through
its crisis of meaning so the question is
well where do you find the spirit that
revives and the answer is in the darkest
possible place and and see this is where
I think that conservatives go wrong my
lectures well tonight wasn't
particularly a classic example but my
lectures tend to be very dark there was
darkness in this one I mean there there
there is a inalienable reality of
finitude and suffering that
characterizes people's lives and it's
not surprising that they become bitter
they become embittered and resentful and
that has to be that has to be
forthrightly examined as deeply as
possible before anything optimistic can
emerge because you have to say look I
understand why you're you feel the way
you
but despite all that and all of that is
a lot that proper antidote is the
ethical way of life and not only is it
the proper antidote because it's your
duty which is another thing that
conservatives stress it's deeper than
that it's because it actually works no
you need you need a meaningful life it's
not optional because that combats the
suffering and more than that if you lead
a meaningful life which means to adopt
responsibilities almost inevitably you
actually make things better and so you
can take people down to the bottom of
the abyss and you can say it's no wonder
that you despair
given your finitude but there's so much
possibility that surrounds you that you
can make something of that regardless of
its of the reality of its horror and you
do that with responsibility and people
understand that and so it it isn't just
a call to make making things better it's
not a call to a utopia that's produced
by a human imagination it's it's it's a
minute it's it's it's the insistence
that without the proper engagement in
truth that your life will your life will
degenerate and you will end up
embittered and in hell and so the
conversation just hasn't been serious
enough I would say and that's especially
bad for young people you know one of the
things I tell young people all the time
I'm not a very typical psychologist in
this regard because I call it just like
to Pat people on the head and say you're
all right the way you are
I talked to Bishop Baron a while ago I'm
gonna broadcast this and he said that
the Catholic priests were trained in the
1960s to kind of be accepting you know
humanistically
you're okay the way you are you know and
that's such rubbish it's like not only
are you not okay the way you are you
don't think that anybody else is okay
the way they are either you know you
don't think your children are okay the
way they are like you love them and all
that but you don't want them to stay
three years old their entire life you
want them to expand and improve and
become who they are and so instead of
telling young people that they're okay
the way they are I tell them that and
it's a terrible message for them if
they're desperate you know so let's say
ten and percent of the people in my
audience are young maybe they're young
men just for the sake of argument and
they're like not in good shape they
don't have any giggles there they're
drinking too much they're watching
pornography all the time they've got no
aim they've got no structure in their
life and they're just bloody miserable
and the misery is twisting them into
malevolence because enough misery will
absolutely do that to you and then what
are you gonna do and come along and say
well you're you're okay the way you are
it's like that's the last thing they
want to hear it's like get your damn act
together you know you got things to do
and they're gonna be difficult and that
there's a there's a there's a an echoing
Christian message in there I would say
which is you pick up the weight of your
suffering voluntarily and you walk
uphill with it and that not only gives
you the meaning that you need in life in
your life to stop you from degenerating
in a dangerous manner but it actually
makes things better and so that that
that all has to be part of it like I
believe in human ingenuity I think we
can solve all the problems that beset us
but it can't just be it has to be more
than we can enhance material well-being
that's just what it tends to be now it's
not enough and so and you get brushed
off by the apocalyptic types yeah
there's that that creativity that only
comes from the individual consciousness
and it can't be simply reduced to some
kind of a formula or a machine
it's it's mysterious in some way which
is why I think your recourse to the
archetypal structures of Genesis is so
illuminating but there was one thing you
said about that that I just wanted to
pursue a little bit if I may the idea
that we can't not operate like this is
what's especially compelling in your
look yeah exactly good luck precisely
that's the thing that's so strange is
that you know
Nietzsche thought we could create our
own values right that was his solution
to the death of God right but you can't
because while Dostoyevsky figured this
out right in crime and punishment for
example you try breaking a moral rule
especially one of your own mmm-hmm and
then try convincing yourself that it's
okay it's like good luck with that man
you break a moral rule that's
sufficiently deep you'll traumatize
yourself and you'll never recover and if
you break one that's you know maybe just
a medium-sized well all that'll happen
is you'll wake up at 3 in the morning
you know night after night perhaps for
years torturing yourself because of the
mistake you made it if you could create
your own values you dispense with that
in two seconds you'd say well that was
my decision there's no fundamental
meaning to reality whatsoever I can do
whatever I choose and I'm not gonna be
guilty about it it's like and the point
is that's neither neither true nor donk
tional it's it's that's it's it's
neither truth ya function yeah and it's
functional in a psychopathic manner well
the closest people and people who are
closest to be able to do that are
psychopaths but like their outcomes
aren't that great they don't have
they're not they don't do that well
despite what you read about you know
psychopathic CEOs they don't do that
well and most people caught on to their
tricks and generally they spend nomadic
lives because they have to go from place
to place because people catch on to
their deceit and you know they're quite
prone to suicide and and spontaneous
emotional collapse so no you you have
this moral law that you exactly yeah but
this is one way in which our position as
being image bearers of God is a
misleading
parallel insofar perhaps as God uses his
words to create bring order a create
order out of chaos and we can create
order to by speaking truly the
difference being that we don't know
whether there were any constraints at
all constraining his choice at the
beginning of the process but we do know
that we live within a context ourselves
both physically physically naturally as
well as morally that constrains our
choice we can either recognize our moral
obligations as you said or try and elide
them when it's not successful but we can
try and I just noticed one thing that
seems a little odd you can tell me if to
strike you as odd or not or maybe I'm
missing something in an era when
identity politics seems to be everything
and as you said a lot of post-modernism
has devolved into this notion that
there's nothing but competing groups
with their different self-contained
mindsets competing for power and what
never the twain shall meet
epistemological II and so forth that's
certainly the case and at the same time
doesn't there seem to be coexisting with
that a kind of mutated individualism
which is alike what you just mentioned
of Nietzsche namely the idea that I can
I'm an individual I'm the creator of a
meaning I can use my own words or my own
will to create my own identity I'm not
obligated to independent moral
obligations I create moral obligations
yeah how can this kind of mutate a toxic
individualism coexist with identity
politics well I say the things things
that you cheat what is it you can chase
nature Oh with a pitchfork but she
always comes rushing back in right you
know if you if you one of the things I
tried to do in maps of meaning which was
the first book I wrote was to write a
description of what distinguished a
religion from ideology and one of the
things that distinguishes our religion
from an ideology as a religion takes
everything into account it's like well
there's a tyrannical element of culture
but there's also the benevolent element
and there's the tyrannical element or
the destructive element of nature but
there's also the creative element and
there's the heroic element of the
individual which would be embodied say
in Christianity in the figure of Christ
but there's also the adversary
there's always this balance yeah with if
you think everything is a social
construct so it's all social well the
individuality is going to creep back in
somewhere and it does it in exactly the
form it's this very very childish form
right because it's so immature it's so
underdeveloped it's like well we're
entirely socially constructed except at
moment to moment we can determine our
gender and by our own individual choice
and everyone has to bow down to that yes
yes well that's also what makes it so
childish is that not only not only is it
in the incoherent doctrine because you
can't have it both ways
you're not socially constructed and able
to choose your gender those things don't
go together but the idea that your
identity now self-produced
also takes precedence over the
negotiation you have to have with other
people about what your identity is going
to be is really at the same development
level I would say as a two-year-old and
I mean that I mean that technically
because two-year-olds two-year-olds
cannot take their own identity and
integrate it with the identity of other
children they can't do that until
they're about three and so it's so it's
it's so infantile that it's almost
beyond imagination like epistemic
solecism meaning meaning I mean that the
idea that only I exist that soloff's is
amiss so that yeah that I therefore I
know only what I know but everyone else
doesn't really exist everyone else is an
illusion I only am familiar with my own
thoughts and the only true reality is
the reality that I experience everyone
it's like except you can't live
consistently with that and no one does
well but guess those aren't identities
it's this is another thing that's so
immature about it it's like okay you're
gender fluid fine
well now what I'm dead serious
I'm dead serious like what the hell are
you gonna do with that you know like
part of the reason you have gender roles
and and of course their tyrannical and
constricting you know obviously because
everybody gets taken by culture and
crushed into something that's a
compromise between their individuality
and the rest of
world everyone suffers from that but you
know if you're if you're let's say
you're straight and you're heterosexual
for sorry those are the same thing let's
say you're heterosexual and you're
monogamous and you're in a committed
relationship so like all of a sudden you
have an identity well what's the
identity well it's easy you get married
you have children you raise them
together you tie your lives together you
try to you try to build something for
the decades right and that's an identity
it's a pathway forward it's it's a way
to be well I'm gender-fluid it's like
okay well pick your pronoun it's like
okay well what do you do tomorrow well
I'm I don't know I'm out there in
no-man's land you don't want to be in
no-man's land that's not good you're off
the beaten path you think well I can go
off the beaten path it's like you go off
the beaten path and you just see how
long you last you're lucky if you're if
you're a highly creative person and
you're very disciplined and you have
most of your life in pristine order you
might be able to risk a substantial
deviation from the beaten path and
managed to maintain your sanity but if
you're a disorganized person and you
wander off the pathway of tradition you
are in so much trouble you can't even
possibly imagine it there are things out
there that you will encounter that you
have absolutely no defense against
whatsoever and so it's naive beyond
comprehension slike well I'm a new kind
of gender it's like you've got 60 years
to figure that out and then take fifty
thousand years to even take a crack at
it
so it's terrible
Mary did you have another question you
want to ask I think we can slip one in
because I think one more you okay you
talk about how dangerous it is to tell
some young person whose life is messed
up that they're just great the way they
are with which I completely agree but
how do you reach a young person who's
bought into the notion that life is
meaningless well you're the first thing
is you tell them why they think that
it's like they've got all sorts of
reasons to think that it's like life is
hard it's it's it's a crucifixion that's
right and so it's no wonder they think
that it's like okay fine first of all
we're gonna take it seriously yeah
you're suffering and adrift and you have
your reasons but you need so you take
those reasons seriously and you say
despite that despite that there's more
to you than you think and you know that
- because you upgrade yourself for not
manifesting it and you say to people
well I ask people for example who do you
admire because that's the instinct for
admiration is part of the instinct for
imitation it's like how do you admire
admire people who are completely
irresponsible you admire people who
can't take care of themselves they can't
even take care of themselves here's the
most admirable person completely useless
to themselves maybe even
counterproductive just a bloody
catastrophe for their family and like
what would you call a social danger like
no one admires that no one admires that
it's like you start minimally can you
take care of yourself at least that
that'd be the first thing and then is
there more than eyes there enough to you
so that maybe someone else could rely on
you now and then maybe maybe a number of
people maybe your family it could be a
it could be the glue that holds them
together and and amends them and then
maybe there could be more to you than
that maybe you could be someone for your
community and god only knows how far you
could go with that those are the people
you admire it's like well try that out
see what happens and start locally young
Carl Jung said this is one of my
favorite Carl you
quotes that modern man does not see God
because he will not look low enough I
really like that and so you know I've
been telling the people that I talk to
the same thing it's like you have a
certain amount of potential within your
grasp you may find what you have
contemptible because you're not in a
position of power this modicum of
possibility that's been granted to you
is beneath you and so you do nothing
with it and so you get nothing from it
you take that seriously you do the small
things you can the humble things that
you can to put yourself together in that
in those tiny embarrassing ways that are
real and if you do that enough you'll
you'll four will fortify yourself and
that will work and you know one of the
things that's been unbelievably
hardening to me it's ridiculous really
like normally now if I go out during the
day if I go to any city I've been to
like 150 cities in the last year and if
I'm walking around on the street or in
an airport someone will come up to me
about every 10 minutes or so and they'll
say the same thing they always say the
same thing they first of all apologize
for bothering me and they're very polite
to all my interactions with people you'd
never guess this from like my reputation
in the press but all my interactions
with people in public are unbelievably
positive and the people will come up and
say you know I was in this small domain
of hell a year ago or six months ago
whatever it is addiction alcoholism I
wasn't getting along with my family I've
been living with my girlfriend for five
years and we were stuck I didn't have
any direction for my career I was
nihilistic you know I was whatever
you know although different ways that
people can fall into a pit and and and
and be miserable said I read in your
books or I watched your lectures and I
decided I was gonna I was gonna try to
put my family together
or I was gonna I was gonna make a vision
and pursue it or it's going to try
telling the truth I was just
try one of these things and things are
way better way better you know and
sometimes it's a father and a son or
sometimes it's a son and a daughter it's
usually it's usually it's not often a
daughter and a mother not so much but I
mean if it's a pair of people but or
it's a girlfriend and a boyfriend and
the girlfriend is very happy usually
because her boyfriend has straightened
up substantially and maybe they're
getting married and like he's half
civilized at this point but but but it's
but it's it's an unbelievably positive
thing to see and and it's a real thing
you know it's like it's it's so
interesting to watch the fact that all
people have to do is put some of these
things into practice and all of a sudden
that little more to come of potential
that they had because they got humble
enough to deal with it properly starts
to expand and expand and like I believe
and I do believe this and I think this
is part of the Christian message
fundamentally is that there's actually
no limit to that expansion you know
because in some sense like we are this
weird combination of finite and infinite
like we're related to the infinite in
some manner obviously because the
infinite exists and here we are and so
we're related to it in some manner and I
don't know what manner that is but I
don't know what the limits are it's like
if you were the best person you could be
no truly if you decided to live by truth
and to aim at the good and you really
did that you put your whole heart and
soul into it like you were like that's
what you were staking your life on
because you're staking your life on
something who the hell could you be and
no one knows you know you know perfectly
well you could be far more than you are
and you don't know what the oppor limit
of that is and we certainly don't know
what the upper limit would be if there
were lots of people doing that god only
knows what problems we could solve you
know there's lots of suffering and
misery in the world
plenty and it's no wonder that people
get bitter but God as you pointed out
before you know we've got no shortage of
ingenuity and possibility and if we were
serious about making things less
wretched than they are who knows what
miracles we could pull off
[Music]
I want I want to especially thank dr.
Peterson again for his brilliant
courageous and inspiring work and we're
particularly grateful to all of you for
joining with us tonight I want to also
especially thank the wonderful people
who've made tonight possible especially
my colleagues that the independent
Institute our team is just fabulous and
thank you for that I particularly want
to thank my colleague Alicia Luthor
who's our director of administration for
all of her support of work and
organizing and overseeing all that made
tonight possible incidentally there are
copies that you may have noticed of 12
wheels for life outside signed copies
please visit our website at independent
dot org for information about upcoming
events and publications and more we look
forward to seeing you again at future
independent Institute events thank you
and good night
[Applause]
[Music]